ελιγήσαμε όλι λι μας δηλαδή ήταν κάτι το που δεν μποργούσαμε να το φανταστούμε εκτός
από τον αιθρό σταυρο στη ζωή της κυρας παβαδόπουλου υπάρχει και το ίδριμα λεβέντης είναι
και λεβένταιο πινακοθήκι είναι και το φαοντέον για υποτροφίτο μουσίο και το μουσίο πλούσιαπλούσω αυτόν
το έργο βλέπε τον κόσμο να το αγκαλιάζει ναι αι πιστεύω τι και το και
το μουσίο που εξεήταν το ξεκίνημα στην κύπρο το λευαίνιο δημοτικό μουσίο που είναι το
έργο της καιρίας λουκίας χατζί αυγήλιότι εκείνηται που το ανέλαβε από την αρχί κάλιας αν
υπολίτες ναι ναι και σιγάσιγά καιδοραές εγίνουνταν προς το μουσίο που είι ότι σημαντικό να
ο κόσμος να νιώθει ότη μπορεί να πάρει μια συλλογεί που έρχει που ε μπορε
να μηίν ενδιαφέρει τους κληγονόμους του και να το ποσθέριστο το μουσίο ναι και τοεγκαλιάζων
και επιστεύω ότι και το μουσίο και η πινακωθεήκη είναι πραγματικά ένα σύνγια τηλεύκωσα νένα
κόσμημα διότι και επινακωθήκη πιστεύω εείναι στο ιδοστίσμο να δική στην κύρ και είστε κα
δίπλα από τους φίητες δίνονται και υποτροφίεανείναι από το ίδρημα λεβέντη γίνουνται δορς αλλά γίνονται
και πολλάαλλά πράματα και σε όλο τω σε λο τον κόσμο και να πω ότι
για την κύπρο ήταν και προπαντός και τον επαναπατρισμό και ικόνο ταισέθουσες που δημιουγηθηκαν σε
διάφορες χόρες με λόγο του ιδρήματος μεαρχειότητες που δε θαέτσι και αλλις δε θα έρχονταν
πίσω στη στην κύπρο προκθέσει χθα πίσω από το δεονο ημούν με την κυρια χασίκα
ευγί και πίαμεσ